[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis einen schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen was im sport
passiert ist da fahren sie von norbert
leben anfragen stunden am tag von mir
unsere großen themen an diesem montag
für sie
kinder impfung beginnt seit heute können
auch 5 bis 11 jährige gegen korona
geimpft werden
demos schlagen immer öfter in gewalt um
die politik zeigt sich besorgt über die
radikalisierung von corona protesten
peinliche panne bei der champions league
auslosung erst im zweiten versuch wird
bayern münchens nächster gegner salzburg
gezogen
wer ein kleineres kind hat kann es jetzt
also gegen korona impfen lassen seit
heute werden dafür in deutschland die
ersten impfstoffdosen von beyond
eckpfeiler ausgeliefert was die korona
lage angeht meint
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
dass sie sich langsam stabilisiere aber
noch heißt es impfen impfen impfen
schauen wir uns dazu die zahlen an von
den gut 69 millionen volljährigen
deutschland sind 80,3 prozent
vollständig geimpft bei den viereinhalb
millionen 12 bis 17 jährigen sind es
knapp 49 prozent
nun werden also auch die gut fünf
millionen fünf bis elfjährigen
berücksichtigt für sie stehen erst
einmal 2,4 millionen impfstoffdosen zur
verfügung dominik möller russ l
berichtet
um 13 uhr ist der impfstoff eingetroffen
in der kinderarztpraxis dr achenbach in
plettenberg im sauerland florian und
franziska 5 und 6 sind die ersten der
pulli klemmt doch dann kann es losgehen
es ist überstanden erleichterung und
vorfreude auf ein wieder normaleres
leben gerade auch bei den kindern
[Musik]
die impfung lasse ich die kinder nicht
ein indoor spielplatz gehen ich zu viel
kontakt mit anderen kindern haben
wenn ich gehen und dann auch wieder zu
meinen großeltern kann sie handhaben es
so in der praxis achenbach zunächst
kinder mit vorerkrankungen oder mit
gefährdeten personen in ihrem umfeld
aber auch alle familien die angst haben
oder sich einfach eine impfung wünschen
sollen dran kommen können da kann man
mit der impfung vielleicht auch das den
angst level den stresslevel in der
familie senken also wobei die familien
müssen schon von selber auf mich
zukommen und mich fragen wir laufen
niemand damit der spitze hinterher
kinderärzte impfen ab heute in den
impfzentren soll es in den kommenden
tagen losgehen vorbereitet auf rege
nachfrage
ich glaube wenn ich auch an die neue
variante von nikon denke dass es gute
gründe gibt auch kinder die nicht vor
erkrankt sind zu impfen weil das
natürlich auch teilhabe zum beispiel an
einer regelmäßigen schulunterricht und
vieles andere uns ermöglichen wird
impfstoff scheint stand heute
ausreichend da zu sein die praxis
achenbach zumindest hat 300 dosen
bekommen wie bestellt
blicken wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen da fehlen heute aufgrund
technischer melde probleme allerdings
die werte aus niedersachsen das robert
koch institut meldet 21 1743
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
6000 93 weniger als vor einer woche
116 menschen starben binnen 24 stunden
im zusammenhang mit kobe 19 die inzidenz
sinkt auf 3
189,2
gegen die korona maßnahmen kommt es
immer wieder zu teils gewalttätigen
protesten
nicht nur aber gerade auch in sachsen
knapp 20 pfarrerinnen und pfarrer der
evangelisch lutherischen landeskirche
dort haben sich darüber jetzt in einem
aufruf entsetzt und besorgt gezeigt wenn
zur lynchjustiz gegen mitbürger und
demokratisch gewählte volksvertreter
aufgerufen wird ist das erträgliche maß
überschritten heißt es auch die politik
ringt mit einer antwort auf die proteste
cornelia schiemenz
saalfeld in thüringen ist heute abend
einer von zahlreichen protesten
deutschlandweit nach einem wochenende wo
vielerorts die demonstrationen gegen die
korona maßnahmen in gewalt ausarteten
die protestler finden sich über
messenger dienste wie telegram zusammen
oft von rechtsextremen organisiert hier
wird gehetzt zu morden aufgerufen und
hier werden feindes listen geführt
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser
sucht nach möglichkeiten telegram direkt
zu fassen gegen hetze gewalt und hass im
netz müssen wir entschlossener vorgehen
die bundesministerin hat damit deutlich
gemacht dass das ein schwerpunkt ihrer
politik sein wird die sie jetzt an geht
wo sie mit den experten darüber reden
wird und auch innerhalb der
bundesregierung darüber sprechen wird
was man tun kann um diesem phänomen noch
stärker als bisher zu begegnen das
problem telegram ignoriert bisher alle
aufforderungen sich an deutsches recht
zu halten der bundesjustizminister sieht
sich dennoch ausreichend gerüstet all
das verstößt heute schon gegen geltende
strafrecht wir haben an dieser stelle
also kein gesetzes- defizit sondern wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die geltende
rechtslage auch durchgesetzt wird und
das sei ländersache in den ländern hat
man derzeit vor allem mit der
bewältigung der protestwelle zu tun in
sachsen treffen sich menschen an bis zu
70 orten gleichzeitig zu sogenannten
spaziergängen illegal da sich in sachsen
nur zehn menschen zusammenfinden dürfen
demokratie ist ja keine kein zustand
sonne ist eine haltung wir brauchen auch
die zivilgesellschaft denn ich glaube
nur mit polizeilichen mitteln und nur
mit der polizei die pandemie zu
bekämpfen das wird alleine nicht
ausreichen
in saalfeld laufen zur stunde mehrere
hundert menschen durch die stadt
friedlich
wie gefährlich sind radikale impfgegner
warum geht es bei zdf heute live ab 1930
diskutieren sie mit über die zdf heute
app und über die sozialen netzwerke
recherchen über die verbindungen bis ins
rechtsextreme milieu hinein haben wir
online für sie zusammengefasst ebenfalls
in unserer zdf heute
österreich atmet auf drei wochen lang
waren unsere nachbarn im lotto seit
heute ist der beendet allerdings nur für
genesene und geimpfte als die menschen
in österreich am 22 november in die
verordnete auszeit gegen betrug die
inzidenz gut 1100 heute nun liegt der
wert bei
333,5 mit verzögerung verbesserte sich
auch die situation auf den
intensivstationen etwas von 658 kurve
patientinnen und patienten vor einer
woche auf jetzt 580 fälle wolf christian
ullrich berichtet
österreich atmet auf nach drei wochen
lockdown hier in tirol können skifahrer
endlich auch wieder in die hütte dort
wartet der dampfende germknödel auf
geimpfte und genesene ich habe meiner
schwester von whatsapp geschrieben dass
ich heute der glücklichste mensch auf
der ganzen welt glaube ich bin die
regeln sind jedoch in jedem bundesland
unterschiedlich in wien etwa bleiben die
kaffeehäuser diese woche noch zu in
vorarlberg dagegen wo die sieben tage
inzidenz derzeit am höchsten ist kriegen
die geimpften ein bier serviert
ungeimpfte bleiben überall im lockdown
ein flickenteppich von regeln die
bundesregierung verteidigt das und
gleichzeitig einen weiteren lockdown für
alle nicht ausschließen und die experten
experten rechnen mit der nächsten welle
im jänner das entscheidend wird sein wie
gut vorbereitet sind wir jetzt nochmal
meine bitte an alle die da jetzt zu
hören da dreht die stich ist ganz
entscheidend in österreich geht ab erst
im februar eine impfpflicht zehntausende
hatten dagegen am wochenende
demonstriert darunter die rechtsextreme
szene und die fpr doch eine knappe
mehrheit in österreich unterstützt die
impfpflicht inzwischen
österreich hat nun den vierten harten
lockdown ertragen die sieben tage
incidents ist dabei deutlich gesunken
doch die krise auf den intensivstationen
ist längst nicht ausgestanden und jetzt
nimmt omikron fahrt auf solange die
impfraten niedrig sind könnte der
nächste locker und deshalb schneller
kommen als vielen lieb ist
im ukraine konflikt verschärft russland
den ton der stellvertretende
aussenminister riad kopf drohte mit
militärischen schritten sollten usa und
nato nicht zu sagen dass sich das
bündnis nicht weiter nach osten
ausdehnen um den konflikt ging es auch
beim treffen der eu außenministerin
minister mit den usa und großbritannien
prüfe man welche sanktionen verhängt
werden könnten so der eu
außenbeauftragte buche zudem wurden
strafmaßnahmen gebilligt gegen eine
russische söldnertruppe wegen aktion in
der ukraine syrien und libyen
zurück nach deutschland
die neue ampel koalition braucht viel
geld um die wirtschaft klimafreundlicher
zu machen das kabinett billigte daher
heute einen nachtragshaushalt für dieses
jahr 60 milliarden euro an bisher
ungenutzten krediten für die korona
krise soll nun stattdessen in ein
energie- und klimafonds fließen ein
haushalts kniff der bei der opposition
nicht gut ankommt frank buchwald
berichtet
erste kabinettssitzung und der neue
finanzminister bringt gleich ein
nachtragshaushalt mit lindners ziel mehr
geld für den klimaschutz
wir sichern 60 milliarden euro
zusätzliche investitionen
in die zukunft und in die gestaltung
einer klimaneutralen technologie nation
an der geplanten neuverschuldung von gut
240 milliarden euro ändert sich zwar
nichts sein nachtragshaushalt aber ist
nötig weil lindner 60 milliarden nicht
abgerufener corona kredite nutzt um den
klimafonds aufzufüllen für investitionen
in den klimaschutz denen damit nun
76,2 milliarden euro bereit die
opposition jedoch skeptisch wir können
im augenblick mehr geld ausgeben mehr
schulden aufnehmen ausnahmen von der
schuldenbremse mache allein aus einem
grund wegen der korona folgen man will
das geld aber jetzt nutzen um
digitalisierung und klimaschutzprojekte
damit zu finanzieren
das passt bei dem engen rahmen die die
verfassung setzt damit nicht zusammen
und leider haben spd und grüne sich von
christian linder an der nase herumführen
lassen die spd dagegen spricht von einem
aufbruchsignal
wir versuchen mit diesem
nachtragshaushalt deutschland alle
möglichkeiten zu geben zu investieren da
wo es nötig ist klimaschutz
digitalisierung transformation der
betrieben die ampel setzt darauf dass
der klimafonds größere private
investments anschiebt für mehr wachstum
ob diese rechnung aber aufgeht hängt
nicht zuletzt von corona ab
auch diese entscheidung der neuen
regierung soll den klimaschutz
voranbringen wer ein e-auto da ein
hybrid fahrzeug kauft kriegt weiterhin
vom staat geld das ende nächsten jahres
gibt es demnach bis zu 9000 euro
förderung für reine e autos etwas
weniger für hebriden hintergrund für die
verlängerte prämie ist laut wirtschafts
und klimaministerium auch dass viele
bereits bestellte pkws später
ausgeliefert werden können
ja aber bibliothek blog for job klingt
wie fachsimpelei betrifft aber unzählige
firmen denn diese software element lok
vor jay wird zum beispiel von apple
tesla amazon auf ihren server benutzt
das problem es gibt darin eine
sicherheitslücke ein einfallstor für
hacker das bundesamt für sicherheit in
der informationstechnik hat die höchste
warnstufe rot ausgerufen bdi-chef
schönbohm heute eine erfolgreiche
ausnutzung der schwachstelle ermöglicht
eine vollständige übernahme des
betroffenen systems sven regn
auf dem server von it-spezialisten
christian bennefeld in hamburg sind die
ersten angriffe am freitag aufgelaufen
die angreifer nutzen eine
standardfunktion von webservern das
vereinfacht gesagt hallo oder
identifikations protokoll dass vergab
welchen rechner welches betriebssystem
und welchem browser benutzt der besucher
diese identifikation die wird jetzt
manipuliert durch den angreifer
dahingehend dass der protokoll server
angewiesen wird ein stückchen
programmiercode auszuführen und dieser
programmiercode der kann dann eben auf
daten des servers zugreifen
dieses begrüßungs protokoll gibt es seit
jahren und es ist open source meint
jeder kann den programmcode einsehen und
auf fehler untersuchen den aktuellen
fehler hat oder wollte bislang niemand
finden betroffen sind viele unternehmen
die dienstleistungen im web anbieten
sind große namen betroffen wie tesla zum
beispiel eben auch apple ist betroffen
viele große firmen und das heißt im
umkehrschluss dass einerseits die
hersteller betroffen sind andererseits
natürlich aber auch die endkunden die
dann dementsprechend die services nutzen
besonders folgenschwer dabei die
angreifer können sich eine eigene
hintertür ins system einbauen durch
diese schadsoftware einschleusen auch
wenn die aktuelle lücke längst
geschlossen ist es ist letztlich als
würde man eine art schläfer irgendwo
postieren da verhält sich erst mal
unauffällig und irgendwann wenn es
einmal den kram passt dann schlägt man
zu und sagt so jetzt installiere ich da
aber noch irgendetwas besonders gemein
ist drauf und erpresse beispielsweise
die firma auch das bundesamt für die
sicherheit in der informationstechnik
befürchtet dass die eigentlichen
probleme gerade für kleine firmen noch
kommen immerhin für die sicherheitslücke
im begrüßungs protokoll gibt es
inzwischen ein update und
wir bleiben im cyberspace denn das
landgericht trier hat die betreiber
eines unterirdischen rechenzentrums für
kriminelle geschäfte zu mehrjährigen
freiheitsstrafen verurteilt
im sogenannten cyberbunker prozess bekam
der hauptangeklagte aus den niederlanden
fünf jahre und neun monate in dem
ehemaligen bundeswehr bunker in traben
trarbach hatten die acht angeklagten
geheimes server für kunden betrieben
über die um dort mit fast 250.000
straftaten abgewickelt wurden dabei ging
es unter anderem um drogendeals
falschgeld und cyber angriffe
es ist ein kleiner hoffnungsschimmer
inmitten der trümmer und zerstörungen
bei den verheerenden tornados in den usa
könnten am wochenende weniger menschen
ums leben gekommen sein als zunächst
befürchtet in der nacht zum samstag
waren dutzende wirbelstürme in sechs
bundesstaaten über das land gezogen
unser reporter benjamin daniel ist in
mayfield einer kleinen stadt in kentucky
die besonders schwer getroffen wurde
martinz hatte dieses haus mit seinen
eigenen händen gebaut ein lebenswerk in
trümmern
das hier war die küche oder was davon
übrig ist da wir hatten gerade erst den
geschirrspüler und den kühlschrank neu
gekauft alles zerstört
der 59 jährige lebte hier mit seiner
frau als sie flüchten wollen ist der
tornado bereits da reißt in minuten fast
das ganze haus mit sich matti kann kaum
begreifen was passiert ist er wurde von
einem dachbalken getroffen eingeklemmt
und konnte sich schließlich befreien
hier am türrahmen habe ich mich versucht
hochzuziehen da sieht man noch die
abdrücke meiner blutigen hand
mathys hausstand im herzen der schwer
getroffenen kleinstadt wakefield helfer
packen rund um die uhr mit an um
zunächst die trümmer wegzuräumen der
gouverneur spricht von der schlimmsten
tornado serie die den bundesstaat je
getroffen hat
wir haben uns alle so sehr auf
weihnachten gefreut und dann kam das
wir können nur dankbar sein dass wir
noch am leben sind
dass die zahl der todesopfer in den
betroffenen bundesstaaten insgesamt wohl
doch nicht so hoch liegt wie vorerst
angenommen wird natürlich auch von den
menschen hier in mayfield positive
aufgenommen nichtsdestotrotz geht man
allein in kentucky weiterhin von mehr
als 60 toten aus und die suche nach
vermissten ist noch immer nicht
abgeschlossen
die hoffnung jetzt noch überlebende zu
finden schwindet allerdings von stunde
zu stunde
und wir kommen jetzt zum sport zur
fußball-champions-league norbert da gab
es auch heute peinliche panne auslosung
ganz schönes chaos aber der fc bayern
münchen der kann sich eigentlich freuen
der sollte nämlich zuerst auf atletico
madrid im achtelfinale treffen starker
gegner dann die pannen alles noch mal
von vorn der neue vermeintlich
angenehmere gegner heißt jetzt rb
salzburg
software probleme lösen eine
kettenreaktion aus die zur annullierung
der gesamten auslosung führt erster
fehler der fc villarreal soll gegen
manchester united antreten obwohl beide
teams schon in der gruppenphase
aufeinander getroffen sind die briten
liegen im falschen los topf
weiterer fehler when you wird nicht in
den richtigen topf zurückgelegt die
auslosung wird aber trotzdem fortgesetzt
was natürlich zu einer
wettbewerbsverzerrung führt bei der
wiederholung bekommt bayern münchen dann
rb salzburg zugelost und nun muss statt
dessen menus sich mit atlético madrid um
den einzug ins viertelfinale
auseinandersetzen
und das sind die neue ausgelosten
achtelfinal-hinspiel begegnungen
salzburg also gegen münchen atletico
gegen manchester united sporting
lissabon trifft auf manchester city
benfica lissabon auf ajax amsterdam
steht sie gegen villarreal gegen
juventus turin inter mailand muss zum fc
liverpool und paris st germain nach
madrid zu real
und pannen los dagegen verlief das
gestrige sonntag abendspiel zwischen
frankfurt und leverkusen die eintracht
drehte die partie nach 0 2-rückstand und
gewann am ende vollkommen verdient mit 5
glückliche frankfurter auf dem rasen und
auf den rängen nach mitreißenden spiel
die gäste aus leverkusen zu beginn
bärenstark patrick schick mit einem
doppelpack sein 20 der 5000 elber der
bundesliga-geschichte dann aber nur noch
frankfurt zwei schnelle treffer zur
halbzeit steht es 2 2 nach der pause ist
ein frankfurter sturmlauf 50 minute
indycar wuchtig 66 minute jakic resolut
und 76 minute so einfach wunderschön 5
zu 2 nach der besten frankfurter saison
leistung der trainer so scheint
sportlich angekommen
und dadurch spiele alle tore und auch
den ersten sieg von greuther fürth
können sie sich bei uns noch mal ganz in
ruhe anschauen den fünfzehnten spieltag
finden sie ausführlich zusammengefasst
bei zdf heute.de und in der zdf- heute-
app das war so ein schöner
morgen gibt's von der sonne leider nur
wenig zu sehen mehr zum wetter gleich
von ersten teil ii zum heute-journal
begrüßt sie um 21 45 bettina schausten
tipps machen sie es gut
[Musik]
ein schirm gute und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter hoher luftdruck bestimmt das
wetter über deutschland und mitteleuropa
allerdings kommt die sonne relativ
selten hervor im norden kommt etwas
regen reingezogen und generell haben wir
es mit vielen wolken vor allem im norden
deutschlands zu tun und so sieht sie in
der nacht aus also häufig bewölkung im
norden und etwas regen was rein zieht es
wird hauptsächlich sprühregen sein ziel
ist es also nicht ganz im süden bildet
sich nebel hier und da klar dass auf wir
gehen die temperaturen vor allem am
alpenrand relativ war und weit runter
bis auf minus vier grad 0 gerade im
südwesten sonst ist es frostfrei mit den
mildesten werten mit 7 grad an der
nordsee ja und im süden deutschlands
zeigt sich durchaus mal die sonne im
tagesverlauf sonst aber weiterhin viele
wolken und sprühregen einzig auch
richtungen schleswig-holstein etwas
sonnenschein mit höchsten temperaturen
von drei grad an den alpen und 9 grad
nach nordwesten hin die kommenden tage
bleiben überwiegend trüb sogar mit etwas
regen am mittwoch sonst kann sich auch
mal die sonne zeigen bei 4 bis 10 grad
am donnerstag und am freitag entweder
sonnenschein nebel oder dichte bewölkung
damit ein schöner abend